un roi n'a pas d'amis
ce
roy est entourée que d'adversaires un
nouveau chapitre de ma vie s'est ouvert
souvenez vous à quoi j'ai passé ma
jeunesse dans l'ivresse lé plaisir
je suis le roi que la prudence soit on
dit on gère j'ai vu aussi la soif de
pouvoir dont ils sont animés
j'ai besoin de mon tour et d'hommes en
qui je peux me fier je suis venu parce
que tu es mon ami je vais venir avec toi
sachez que vous serez gouverné par un
roi d'une tout autre nature
la france vous nargue
ils étaient les ennemis de mon père qui
ne sont pas les miens les cris de vos
hommes
la nuit je serai bercé par les 100 blues
vous renverserait ce roi henry 5
d'angleterre que vous sous-estimez temps
tu prêt pour ce qui nous attend
nature de la guerre des trains si
meurtrière rebelles c'est ainsi que la
paix est forgé
éprouvez un sentiment d'accomplissement
cette famille pour moi
roi d'angleterre êtes-vous inquiet
je sens déjà le fardeau de la couronne
que je porte
[Musique]